previously on TV sins that there is your
m249 satellite machine gun
sometimes referred to as the piglet oh
dear Liam Fox well welcome nothing like
getting that names position out there
right out of the gate huh i interviewee
let me start by saying your full name to
you clearly and with great diction sinks
but also cream flats well to be fair
some actually does float both in the
bathroom and the boardroom for that
matter no really hope to look forward to
seeing you again
damn dude there's stumbling over words
and then there's just not being able to
help yourself from being an [ __ ]
I don't think Liam needs an implanted
digital video recorder to know that his
ass is most likely looking forward to
not getting this job wait is there a
taxi driver driving this car we have
in-memory computing but still don't have
driverless cars make it stop the
dystopia is too much does everyone have
to hear this ad for the implant they
already Kingham every time they start a
playback you've already sold the product
so what is the point of the
advertisement and based on what we learn
it's extremely rare that someone doesn't
have the implant so this is more
pointless than a coke commercial also on
the list of things that shows and movies
think will be in the future but also
seem completely impractical are
transparent screens why would I want the
real world distracting me from my
screens eat up the future also also
we're later shown that you can see
things right in your eye with the brain
technology so why not just watch it
there even the future is an immune from
lazy news position I'm not gonna lie
the execution of this memory storage
concept is bonkers cool and just as a
reminder since you probably don't have a
green installed this was created like
eight years ago I'm just saying the
black mirror is the bee's knees and I
should probably take a couple cents off
now so that I can stop slobbering all
over its cookie for a bit I'm sitting
these bright red socks and there is
nothing you can do to stop me
suck it Red Sox fans but look at that
frayed carpet they all seem to be
obsessed with pausing and rewinding
specific moments over and over again
looking for inconsistencies and mistakes
and black mirror episode or night doctor
who is that let's get you a drink
they're lovely as bujji of a gathering
as this appears to be there is no way
they're serving guests room-temperature
beer damn in the future they've
apparently traded candling for vase ink
because they have an entire room
blocking four-story shelving unit
dedicated all sorts of vase factory
which is two tools in the tool shed that
just fit together really well I can
agree there was at least one tool in
that relationship
this name may or may not rhyme with
bonus I'm a serial monogamist
I'm staying faithful to my cornflakes
right now dude Grape Nuts was right
there for the taking well I think it's
an interesting choice going brainless
gluten allergies parents are going full
grain brain in their babies I mean
that's dark man with all the growth and
brain change at that age wouldn't it
have to be swapped out often and at what
point do you give them control of their
own grain could do a whole episode of
black mirror based on the privacy issues
but that would be a little bit too
repetitive for a show this could wait
I'm not done going off on these stupid
future screens not only is the
transparency ridiculous they are
reflective as hell and they're wasting
about a foot of screen real estate
around the edges just with glass it's
obvious whoever designed this was going
for over-the-top aesthetics as opposed
to real-life use so apparently Apple won
the technology wars then because when
you told me about mr. Marrakesh it was a
week Wow he found that very specific
moment awful fast for a system we saw
earlier is manually selected through a
scrolling menu took me 30 minutes of
scrolling on my phone to get to a
picture from last week imagine searching
through everything you've ever seen ever
also I know this is all going to end
badly for everyone involved because well
it's black mirror but the problem is the
technology is actually so damn cool it
doesn't even matter to me bring on the
end because I'm installing Google green
release day no questions asked
what is she doing with her hand if we
are supposed to be seeing through his
eyes she's basically just running her
fingers right in front of his face for
some reason the healthy no no that's
brilliant cuz sometimes you're a [ __ ] I
didn't mean that you're a [ __ ]
weird I don't remember him pointing at
her like this isn't this supposed to be
like real video it's not a memory weird
you're a [ __ ]
also sometimes you can't just edit off
the word sometimes Ross and Rachel the
later years for the most part the way
this episode explores the consequences
and natural uses for this technology is
brilliantly using it to remember
people's names for example but the idea
that you would be playing a sexual
experience with the same person while
having sex in a completely different
position with them makes
zero psychological or physical sense I
mean if you had some augmented reality
app with it that could replace your
lover's face and body in real time with
that of a celebrity people would be all
over it but this net romance look I know
ain't the sexiest part of the process
but no one in TV or movies ever seems to
deal with the legitimate effects of
after sex clean up I'm just saying when
you spill some penis colada you should
at least find something with which to
clean it you're gonna catch a little bit
more of the news because when this was
supposedly recorded you said more than
news that's right
watch a little bit of the news so either
you've got a green glitch or the
continuity folks fell asleep at the
wheel
[Laughter]
no is that funny god Danny it really is
me okay it's the future fine I'll give
you the occasional zoom and enhance
cliche allowance but you've tried that
crystal-clear double zoom and enhance
nonsense on me because I don't care what
year it is I'm sitting at like it's 1999
wow this technology just keeps getting
better he's now watching this moment
from behind himself with his own eyes
black mirror is great for many reasons
and this episode embodies a lot of those
qualities you can hear how long in the
background trying to call the police
only to be shown because she doesn't
have the memory thing like everyone else
it also has a main character who is 100%
right about his suspicions but 100%
wrong when it comes to his actions a
hallmark of the series I'm removing
three sins for this but that being said
couldn't you throw them Jonas's grain
feed or is the ease and ubiquity of the
technology only reserved for when the
plot needs it not Boyd and Liam is
having not boy band Jonas delete all the
sex he had with his wife over there six
months together but the screen pulls up
what appears to be 14 moments both in
the pictures and the time lines I'm not
here to judge anyone's sexual frequency
but you have a hot 6-month fling with
someone and you only have sex 14 times
that's just over twice a month it's like
I've had a bad tooth years and I'm just
finally getting my tongue in there I'm
digging out all the rotten you're
digging run out of your tooth with your
tongue he'll England this whole montage
of memories that show feel of Liam even
though he was right about her cheating
on him but wrong that she didn't love
him and only him and Liam realising it
is awesome heartbreaking and we're
taking off two more since
you who walks behind the rows will
decide your fate sinks but also cream
flats keep telling yourself that darling
hang on wrong right back up
zoom in there who are you projection
reality or AI interface cuz if your
interface those excellent nose house
here you are sir one políticas the
enzyme shake do me a favor will he throw
that down the toilet cut out the
middleman Jonas is it all fling no I'm a
serial monogamist up I'm staying
faithful to my cornflakes right now now
is that funny no I'm Marla Koba no